I hear they're gonna make alcohol
completely legal in Denver no way I'm
like so than 7-eleven like weed
yup that's crazy no I read it in height
is that the guy yeah that's scary no you
just act fool then he'll act are you
Allison here's a six-pack that's only 2
3 bottles I said here's your six packs
so what brings you in for an alcohol
prescription uh I've just been feeling
like a little anxious and I've been
having some trouble sleeping this will
definitely help him be medicated before
drink it right you could drink it you
could like guzzle it you could like get
on your hands put it in your mouth you
could do it in like a lot of little
glasses you could just kind of like
figure out what works for your body okay
great
do you have your license yeah I do okay
uh I trust you oh you're good to go
thank you take care of yourself did you
have an alcohol card here'd you got a
card I'm having a party this weekend
give me a little help sure
so I just fill this out and then I could
go in and they'll give me whatever I
want
yep do they take credit cards nope
there's an ATM machine with a six dollar
surcharge whoops no cellphones
I got ma'am Oh Oh I am a prescription
doesn't matter you can't have this much
in public
this is intent to distribute let's go
why don't you just smoke weed like
everyone else it's healthier
[Music]